this is simply to make people better and
to make them recognize that they don't
have to get stuck where they are but
they can change because every every day
is an opportunity of change it's a big
one today because my guest is Arnold
Schwarzenegger hasta la vista baby this
conversation which Arnold graciously
hosted in his office slash Museum of
spectacular artifacts collected over the
course of his storied life covers the
principles he leveraged to stratospheric
success in three distinct careers
bodybuilding movie stardom and politics
all of which are eloquently distilled in
his new book The useful Arnold also
shares his thoughts on confidence ego
and ambition we need to get stronger we
need to get tougher we have to be
willing to go through hardship
through suffering
through pain we talk about his
commitment to the environment his
relationship with James Cameron and also
this very interesting fourth act that he
now finds himself in which is all about
service giving back being a voice of
positivity and leveraging his influence
for the betterment of others this one
was quite the thrill so please enjoy
Arnold as perhaps you have never before
seen or hurt him
when I think about your life and and
your journey this young person who who
knew early and often that he belonged in
America had a vision for it visualized
it
architected that Vision into goals that
you pursued and achieved relentlessly to
the point where you you surpass
anybody's expectations of your
capabilities and and reach the absolute
Pinnacle of success in three separate
prominent sectors of society and this
makes you on some level like this iconic
generational uh emblem or example of the
American dream so I'm interested in in
your relationship with your own ambition
and how you've been able to maintain a
grounded ego because you're very much a
person of the people you like staying
connected with people you're all about
people but for a different version of
Arnold that ego could have run rampant
and imploded your life so it could have
yeah you're absolutely right it could
have the only thing is that I think
maybe would help news is that they never
really felt that I have arrived to be
honest with you
not in bodybuilding not in I mean I
pretend
and I do the big Spiel right and I'm the
greatest
I do all of that yes but I mean in
reality I feel like when I work for
instance in the movie
I really don't feel like I it's any
different than being a plumber
and I go to work they put all the
schmutes on and the makeup and I'm
sitting there like an idiot at five in
the morning so that I'm ready at eight
o'clock
and and then they go out and you you do
your work do your scenes then you go and
have your lunch and you know it's it's
like the same it's like going to Brook
yeah and then going back home I don't
see myself as a star
I just see myself as a broker
and uh so when people can say
you're so nice you eat with the crew
I feel like I'm the crew
I'm just one of them right we are all
trying to make a good movie
and so it's like I never really feel
out there kind of like even when I was
governor it no matter where yes I have
my moments where I feel like I always
man that just shows how great I am and
stuff like that but the reality settles
in by the way I I put myself back in the
place and uh even when I've I remember
where I have to make myself kind of feel
like
I'm the Mr Olympia
but when I look in the mirror I see so
many flaws yeah you say that in the
documentary you're you're very
self-critical so many flaws and it's
easier delts are never the big enough
the thighs are comma you know how am I
gonna fake my way through here you know
so that's the way I talk to myself but
then when I go out it says oh I'm going
to show them the day and the the best
part in the world that has ever seen
blah I don't understand
but I mean the the reality of it is I
just always
kind of like felt you know fortunate
that I'm in this situation and but I
don't get like a big head it's because
of it yeah I don't know if in his
private moments Muhammad Ali
thought
yeah I'm not as good as I say like I
think he really believed that so it's
interesting to hear you say
or to to you know be honest about
vulnerabilities or or insecurities I
think that's surprising well I think
that even more mid Muhammad Ali I'm sure
that he had his own moments
of reality because he lost
you know and I know that when he lost he
knew why he lost
and uh but you know he was like he was a
showman yeah and Muhammad Ali was just
an extraordinary showman that had so
much joy in his sport which is extremely
important to find joy in all of the
torch and heart training and uh and also
to be able to
kind of entertain people in that way and
to have a mind that can remember all
this stuff I mean his poetry and all the
stuff that he did he never made a
mistake it's not like he bubbled away
and always and he tripped or something
like that uh you know none of that so it
was just uh great and he had a great
vision
and he always saw himself like
you know that he was done Injustice
and um I think that motivated him to
eventually
get the upper hand of all of that and I
hung out with him a lot in the 70s I
traveled around the United States with
him we went into various different TV
studios did interviews there you know he
was always there first going out there
and doing his interview and all this we
always talked about it hung out with the
same people a lot of times he invited me
to different events he just was really
really good
when I think about those Quiet Moments
where when you're questioning yourself
or or you have those insecurities you
know
where does that
come from I mean you grew up in
challenging circumstances
um
without running water without
a working toilet in your home father
with PTSD who was abusive and drank too
much
these experiences obviously were
formative and and made you who you are
and I know you have a lot of gratitude
for them
but
what's the other side of that
what is the what is the the the pain
Point like when you look back on that
what is your relationship with that
past
when you're not you know on a microphone
and there's cameras I you know a lot of
things we don't choose
I mean I don't choose how I feel
I happen to be fortunate
that I don't have one ounce
of negative thinking about my past
not one else
and I don't know why
you know it's just not there yeah I just
I just have you know I remember the the
tough times
but I also remember very clearly the
sweet times
the gentle times that my father showed
that my mother showed you know how
wonderful they were and how supportive
they were in the schools and the sports
field
with everything even though
they were not kind of like
the American parents
it's so different my parents have never
ever watched me on a soccer game
never ever watched me in a basketball
game or track and field shot with
championships traveling throwing
championships anything like this that we
did in school never ever because no one
did there was no parents hanging around
and saying oh let's watch our kids like
we do over here yeah and the documentary
there's the one where they actually do
show up at that one body but building
competition and and you were confused
well they showed up because my friend
Freddie grossel that I met very early on
invited them and he was a very respected
kind of a man in town and
um they did it for him I I think because
because you know because because he
invited them and so they took it
seriously oh this must be something
special
and then when they saw me up down the
stage I mean it's just like they
couldn't believe it
you know even though I have to say my
mother
sold for me
my bathing suit
because I found some things that was
just too big and I wanted to have it all
cut down so she was sewing with the
sewing machine the day before the
competition I told her I'm gonna go in
the competition and I need a small
bathing suit and so she was sewing it
and I was trying it on for her and it
was doing the fitting and all that stuff
so it was very sweet of her I mean how
many mothers did that but I mean so
there's that side but they just it was
not
the the style then to go into uh watch
kids the only competition that my
parents ever watched was that one
competition in grads
and then one competition in essendon
Germany when I won Mr Olympia for the
third time
and then right after them my father
passed away so I was fortunate that you
saw that there's this
resistance or just refusal on your part
to
to in any way be a victim
and we're in a culture right now where
we're victimhood we have a different
relationship with victimhood I'm sure
that drives you insane and this book is
really speaking to that on some level
like positivity as an antidote for
the lack of agency that a lot of people
feel or the Indulgence with an identity
around victimhood as as powerlessness
right and this is all about calling
people to action to take responsibility
for their lives and giving them Tools in
a road map that it's it's
straightforward advice in this book
right but it's very direct and because
it's from you it's so palpable so
I guess what I'm asking is you know how
do you think about
the way that
our culture now uh thinks about
mental health
uh and and our relationship with this
idea of of powerlessness I think that in
general
I think what the book
is trying to do is
to say to people
you need to work
on yourself
if you just try to be pampered
and if you're trying to be soft
and if you're trying to be the victim
and also you're not going to go anywhere
we need to get stronger
we need to get balls here we need to get
tougher
we need to not be afraid of failure we
got to go into the work we got to face
adversity adversity breeds character
their strength and fighting and
resistance does not only make the muscle
grow but it makes also your head grow
makes you a stronger person we have to
be willing to go through hardship
through suffering through pain through
crying periods all of that stuff don't
shy away from any of that because it
just makes you stronger and I think the
day a lot of times our youth is so into
kind of oh let's make him feel good
oh no let's be more sensitive well I
totally agree with you to be sensitive
about things but I mean there's also a
sweet spot
can we go too far
you know it's like when someone says
well today I just need to sleep in I
said yeah you don't need to
sleep in
this country was not built on sleeping
in
so let's get up in the morning and let's
get on that bike and let's do some
exercise and don't even think about it
don't look at the email or anything like
this let's just get going boom boom boom
let's get going that's the building
and so that's the idea is just not to be
overly soft and overly kind of like
sensitive and everyone is in the victim
kind of a thing I just don't buy into
that
but you have to understand that every
person has to be approached also
differently
it's like the mind is just like the body
I cannot give you exactly the same
training routine that I had
because your body is different you're a
much leaner person you need kind of to
do maybe Melissa reps and what this you
have to have a different diet if you
want the bulk up and all this so I have
to be aware of that that even within my
family one of my daughters had to be
approached differently than my other
daughter one son had to be approached
differently than the other son so you
have to be sensitive about those kind of
things but overall
it was discipline in the house you don't
turn out that light
I will unscrew this light bulbs and you
will be going in the dark room with the
age of three and you'll be scared
so you better start learning the turn of
the little slides you have someone else
make you bad okay I'm gonna take the
mattress and throw it on the balcony and
then you carry it upstairs and you make
your own bed again so this is the way
the my kids screw up
you know and it was like there was
crying there or when I burned their
shoes when she left my daughter left her
shoes for the three times in front of
the fireplace I said the third time it
goes in fire the third time he did go in
the fire right in front of him she was
crying the whole night yeah those things
happen but now she does the same to her
daughter
and now she says that was great that you
did that
you see what I'm saying so now now my
kids were crying on the ski slopes
I don't want to go in I want to go
outside there will be in a hot chocolate
you know the usual Kindergarten Cop kind
of a thing
hot chocolate they said we're gonna ski
four runs and then there's a hot
chocolate
there's enough after the first run yeah
but I'm called to say so am I so what
so what so now let's go be cold and then
go skiing I said The more we ski the
pumps and the more we ski the powder the
warmer we get and the more we warm up it
says let's get going and so now the day
when they come up to Sun Valley with
their friends
to get up
after the dinner with the wine glasses
they want the toast Daddy
because he made us good skiers and
that's why we're here today that's why
we enjoy skiing with all of you
you know how to do that in others but
you know it's it it's it's it's it's not
easy I'm not a psychologist I'm not an
expert with this but one thing I know
for sure I can help anyone to go and be
a little bit better right and I think
that's what we want to ask we cannot ask
everyone to be a genius that's asking
everyone to be the world's strongest man
in order stuff but to be better because
when you're better when you get better
then you feel good when we improve we
feel good when we have accomplished
something we feel good and that then
rubs off on everything that was
beautifully put and it's sort of an
example of this this new role that
you've matured into as this social media
influencer and when I think about the
other three chapters of your life
they're very much a product of having
this vision
adhering to it blinding out everything
as you as you worked your way towards
actualizing that Vision but this feels a
little bit
different
it doesn't feel as much
a product of a goal that you've set for
yourself as much as
this
um
thing that occurred or is a byproduct of
who you are and all of the things that
you've done over the course of your life
you find yourself with this enormous
platform
and you think yourself how can I utilize
this leverage this for good to be useful
to be of service as Governor you're
doing that as an elected representative
of the citizens of California but this
presents a new opportunity to connect
with people directly so I'm curious
around your relationship to social media
and this new kind of
role that you've shouldered around being
a voice of actionable
uh you know positive
uh things that people can do to improve
their lives I have really
no goal
in the how does that feel Arena how does
that feel though like you're doing it
for the for the act of doing it
it's just for other people as opposed to
being it's just
sometimes there's something in US
that is so powerful that you have to
communicate it
you know I remember when nine when when
January 6th happened
it just stayed on me
stayed with me
the thought
and the thought and the thoughts
and it didn't go away
they just started writing things down
what was going through my mind
and it was writing and writing and then
sitting in the jacuzzi and some other
idea came into my mind and then I wrote
it down when I got out and then I was
sitting there and then so it was just it
was just you know they they finally you
know told my guys I said look I think
that we I feel like I should speak up
about that
I said maybe it's my responsibility
maybe not
I said but I feel like it is
I said because I'm a Republican
and I think it is important for people
to know that my president is
Biden
there were no shenanigans
with that election
there was no corruption with this
election
there was no one stealing and walking
out with suitcases of votes and there's
election none of this is true
these are lies
and
and so the more I thought about it the
more I felt like I should say something
and so we put together a speech that was
not thinking more about like being an
influencer or any of those kind of
things you know I was just saying I want
to talk to the American people that it
became what it became I had no idea
that it was covered life for the whole
speech and CNN I know that they're gonna
do that that it was covered all over the
world like that that even the world
cared about January 6th I did not know
you know so that those things we don't
know that always said you know five and
a half six billion people
have become aware of this speech
Isaiah was oh my God this is like wild
so then I realized also at the same time
that there was a need for that obviously
to say that
and so you know so then those things
come up every so often when I see you
know with a certain the Prejudice
growing
and um
people walking around with Nazi flags
and stuff like that
yeah maybe I should say you know
say something about that because so it
it also has to be tied together
organically with me
and so with that I said to myself okay
I think my dad went through that with
the Nazi period
I can I can speak with authority here of
where did they take him what misery did
he go through because of that how there
are no winners ever amongst the haters
and there's always just losers and also
just the pernicious nature of bad
information and yeah exactly what that
can reap yeah so anyway so so then I was
motivated about that and I'm in the
Ukrainian War the Russians unprovoked
attack Ukraine I felt like
you know I should speak up because I
love Russia
and I've been there many times and I
really care for the Russian people
what has happened here right amid
corporate Jeff wonderful man and he has
realized that they have gone in the
wrong direction there and wanted to
straighten it out couldn't do it
um but in any case so I felt kind of
like you know the weightlifters that I
met from Russia and the people that I
met when we opened up Planet Hollywood
in Moscow with wonderful people and
partners we had there all of this kind
of citizens you know this is not
Russia I mean this is Putin and so let's
just talk about that here you know so
that this is what I was trying to
accomplish there's a bust of Lenin over
here in the corner of your office can
you tell the story of how that ended up
here
yes
um
in the early 90s when communism fell
I saw a piece in the New York Times
where they ripped down
a statue of Lenin
and
and that was going on all over the
country
in government buildings where they
ripped down Stalin and Lenin and this
and that and various different leaders
and kind of saying okay this pass didn't
work for us look what happened and we
want to you know kind of reorganize here
and so
it was just peace in the New York Times
how to tear down the statue so I said to
myself
I would like to have one of those this
is history
of them there's a revolution kind of and
them tearing down statues
and Cooperative saying you know this is
the time not for Change and so I got in
touch with my
weightlifting friends in Russia in
Moscow and I said guys
you're tearing down all the sculptures
he says
this is a different and we have to go in
a different direction yeah I said put
them in what are you going to do with
the sculptures
well we're gonna go there and throw them
in a dump somewhere
and now and just to melt them I said I
said don't melt them I said you know
save one for me
you want one yeah so I said I think this
would be said in unbelievable history to
have a sculpture did you guys tore down
for me to keep that it's unbelievable I
think it will be fantastic I would like
to have it okay let me look into it
so
how I feel later
it's the Arnold's classic bodybuilding
championships in Columbus Ohio
and the Russians come every year with
the weightlifting team and the
bodybuilders and so on
and the next thing I know is that we are
having now
to sell up the the after party at the
after competition party big celebration
with thousands of people in the hall and
they roll out this
table that was on wheels
with a covered sculpture
I didn't even know what was in it the
new nervous sculpture it's covered could
have been a cake from from somewhere
he's forgotten about the sculpture thing
it didn't connect the dots at all at
that point so the next thing I know is
they pulled it that the guy goes up
there gives a speech and pourses off
and there's Lenin
and I was like so shocked
it's pretty unbelievable where what was
the statue where was it it was in Saint
Petersburg at the Department of
Agriculture I think it was taught wow
and
um so anyway so we then shipped it home
to Los Angeles and there was out and met
by my swimming pool
was now the sculpture of Lenin and my
wife says why are we having London here
I say I love it I think it's funny I
think they have land in here and so I
had it there for a while
and then the following year
the same guy now rolls out the same
table again
and now he pulls off this cover
and it was Stalin so now it looked
smaller was not exactly the same size
but a little smaller but now it's Stalin
not in here though
the story goes away the following year
after that it was Khrushchev and then it
was on drop off
and it went on and on and on like that
Putin
uh I have a sculpture of Putin
that's part of my Russian collection
where do you keep all of these every
single leader that was leading the
Soviet Union I have in my collection so
I had them all over the swimming pool
and every one of my kind of like natural
things about the fence was there was a
column so I put them on top of the
column so then eventually my wife went
nuts yeah what is this female especially
it was a little bit over there but now I
have it in storage and but in any case
so then I decided okay I'm gonna bring
this one in here uh because it's really
great uh to have him in the office and
to remember then then I found this great
painting that's in the background of
Lenin yeah uh there was I think in the
end or something like that
um so anyway so I thought it was a great
story but in in addition
you you talked about
using your social media platform to talk
about January 6 and and Ukraine Etc but
you also use it to
speak to Ordinary People and to empower
them and talk about the things that you
talk about in this book and what's
interesting about this this role that
you have as sort of a motivational uh
you know self-help Guru for lack of a I
hate that word but on some level like a
a source of inspiration for people
is that on on paper you're very
unrelatable like you've achieved things
that are very difficult for the average
person to understand or connect with
emotionally and yet what you're sharing
in the way that you're sharing it
is so authentic
it really resonates and has connected
with people
all over the world like it's really
powerful what you're doing
so I guess that gets to
what we were talking about earlier about
the fact that that you really are some
you know you you ride your bike around
this neighborhood you go to Golds you're
happy to talk to everyone you could
easily Retreat to your home and live a
quiet private life or insulate yourself
you know with
um you know the the fancy people that
you know and the resources that you have
Etc but you've made a very different
choice
to how to use your energy your
experience your wisdom
in a way where you're sharing it freely
with people people are responding to it
and there's something really beautiful
about that
you know there's a lot of things
that we can take responsibility for and
there's a lot of things we can't
I mean
I don't make that choice
it just it makes me happy
to be with people
I'm a people person so I don't say you
know I should go to the public gym I
think it's cooler than staying at home
and yet during covert I stayed at home
in a trained Image gym at home but I was
in pain
I was in agony
I need people
I need to be out with the people
I like to train with the people I'm a
company Queen yeah you know that's what
they call myself because I just love
being with company I don't like to go to
football games by myself I don't like to
go for dinner by myself I don't like to
work by myself I don't like to go to the
gym and work out by myself I just love
people doing it with people and having a
good time so that's just me so what you
see is me is totally organic nothing is
programmed or anything like that I just
I just
I'm really happy that I can live the
life
that I really want to live
you know that they go to the gym and I
want to go to the gym or at my back when
I want to ride it I ride it to the beach
it's through all of the thousands and
thousands of people on the boardwalk and
Venice with all the tourists there and
it ride my bike through it down to the
Venice Beach with the weightlifting
platform is and all that stuff so I just
go and go to the regular restaurant to
eat with uh all the people there at the
restaurant where I always eat every
morning and um you know that I just I
just love that yeah I hate
when someone makes a reservation for me
and they go let's say to The Palm
restaurant they walk in and they say we
have a table in the corner yeah we have
a table for you we received in the
corner I say I don't want to be in the
corner I said I was sent in the corner
when I was in school
you know you're going to Corner you
kneel in the corner as if a punishment I
said I don't want to be punished I feel
like I'm being punished they're going in
the corner I say I want to sit right
there in the middle of your oldest
people said what's wrong with that table
right over there if you want to sit
right there and I said yeah I said well
there's a lot of people walking in here
and it's okay
I can handle it when someone comes over
to my table and talk to them so it's
that's that I just it makes you have
energy yeah yeah
a lot has been said and has been written
about the three acts you have these
three acts of your career you're now in
this fourth act which is super
interesting and I want to talk to you
about
um but I have a different sort of
perspective on it particularly after
reading the book and and watching the
Netflix series which is to me it feels
less like
three separate acts now and a fourth and
more like this Evolution a gradual
Evolution over time of this person who
went from
a very kind of
through through sheer force of will and
discipline and hard work and all these
things that you all these principles
that you you elucidate in the book of
being very self-oriented and sort of
self you know
uh it's a selfish Pursuit you know to
pursue goals at that level right on some
level it's it's sort of self-reflective
your mirror was your thing
to then kind of grow into this person
who's really all about service like
breaking the Mirror Mirror going from
like me to we it's all one to me it's
all one Big Arc and the book is called
be useful but really it's a call to
service you're basically saying
the best way to improve your life to
feel good about who you are and to find
purpose meaning and fulfillment is to
find ways to give back so
it's not a question it's more just a
reflection that I don't know how does
that land for you yeah I know you're
absolutely right but one should not
forget
that when you start out
you don't have much to give back
so you first have to build yourself
and it became clear to me that the more
I built myself
and the bigger I become the more I can
give back so when I um
um became
Mr Olympia seven six times
and
um
and Special Olympics called me
and said could you come and uh train our
special Olympians and now kids that
intellectually challenged
they don't have the best coordination
they have problems doing sports a lot of
times and be like to do a study on what
effect weight training would have
well I was called
to do that because it was Mr Olympia
that was somebody I was the number one
Authority in bodybuilding
that's why I was calm and so if I
wouldn't have had that I wouldn't have
been able to inspire those young kids
there was 10 kids there and we did this
study for three days and that trained
them and all kinds of great things
happened they got motivated and that's
what launched then with the
international special Olympic Committee
the idea
when and then eventually met my
mother-in-law uh Eunice Kennedy Shriver
who created Special Olympics I told her
about that experience that happened
before I met her and um
I told her I said that I try to
understand kids and they were really
into this powerlifting and they loved it
especially when they gave them the
confidence that they can do it first
there were some of them that were scared
and they were screaming and they were
kind of really worried about the weight
over their head and all this stuff I
said but then eventually we stripped
away that fear and we could see the
Breakthrough and all this I think it
could be very popular she says why don't
you do it in Baltimore it's we have a
meet coming up let's try it in Baltimore
so we did it and it was a huge success
we did it in Washington huge success we
did it in Miami huge success then that
they adopted it in the next meeting
internationally then it became an
international phenomenon so I all of a
sudden became now not something that I
was bargaining for or or or shooting for
or there was never my goal became then
the national coach the world coach for
special and a big strength training with
that
for me to go around now the country and
the world to promote Special Olympics
not just powerlifting but of course you
know being a celebrity eventually every
day instead of doing movies notice I
started traveling around to just start
talking about equal opportunities
I started talking about issues about we
got to get the special Olympians also
the right to have a job the right to
have health care the right to have a
place to stay in the live and there's
equal rights basically equal rights that
they don't have people are prejudiced so
I start talking about those issues that
even while the streams did they ever
think about that's what I would do in my
life but I was able to do that because I
was a star in movies then and and in
bodybuilding and so on so I think the
more I gained of uh you know building
myself the more I was able to give back
in a bigger way right by the time I was
I I campaigned for President Bush in
1988 uh you know and I talked to him on
effos too about training and about the
president's Council of fitness and about
we got to get our kids to get back into
schools back to training and exercising
every day and I was he appointed me to
be the chairman of the president's
Council of Fitness so now I'm going
around over 50 States promoting Health
and Fitness in our Public Schools so
this is like one thing to the next
happened and that's why I mentioned in
my book that
everything that I've done
uh up under that point and I heard
Sergeant Shriver
my father-in-law talk at Yale University
at a commencement speech
he said to the students break that mural
that you always look at
break that mirror that makes you always
look at yourself and he will be able to
look beyond that mirror and to see the
millions of people that need your help
you heard me right that need your help
have you ever thought about going out
and helping and asking himself
that's exactly what's happening to me
so this was a long answer but you were
right when he said it was an evolution
so it starts out with me me me and then
slowly it becomes not just me me but we
we right and so this is what happened to
me and then
as with everything I have an addictive
personality
I started getting addicted to it to give
something back and it made me feel good
and I felt so
rich and so good about myself that I was
able to have this impact and to help
kids to get them you know in schools to
to exercise special Olympians to train
and to do power lifting and to live 500
pounds which they never dreamed of
lifting and and to to go around and
start after school programs then
eventually run for governor yeah the
seeds were there all along though
because it was your dad who said be
useful way back in the beginning it was
my dad that said be useful and it was a
guy that I that I grew up with
that later on in when I was 15 years old
we met that helped us with bodybuilding
and with weightlifting Freddie grossel
that I talked about it became then a
very famous politician in Austria and he
happened to love kids
and to him this was the greatest
investment so in even in his political
career he specialized in building you
know the sports facilities for kids and
everything for kids kids and he paid a
lot of attention to us the other son
also and he invited me over this house
for training and he always talked about
you know giving back
he talked about getting smart just
remember Arnold don't just train your
body but drain also your mind remember
what Plato said in a sound mind sound
body and always talked about that I
wanted to run around with books
underneath your arms and that just
dumbbells and Bubbles and all of this
stuff and so all of this influence that
I had as a young kid
was helpful but especially my father
always saying be useful but that
gentleman I mean he was an incredible
mentor to you uh and he was the guy who
impressed upon you the importance of
developing your mindset of of
cultivating curiosity of asking
questions and listening which bring you
know that brings me back to this whole
podcasting thing right like for me I've
been doing this 11 years
it is an expression of everything you
talk about in the latter part of the
book about making the world your
classroom about seeking out and spending
time with people who inspire you that
you can learn from and learning the
practice of not just engaging with them
but listening learning
so
this has been an incredible experience
for me to continue that Curiosity and
that education into my life and it's
really
how you approach everything that you do
like the fact that you
actively sought out so many interesting
compelling people that you could learn
from and and treated the world as your
classroom and you continue to do that I
mean we're in your office you look
around there's pictures of you with like
all these people we were hearing stories
that you know about uh you know what
you've learned from this person and
you're this sort of Forrest Gump
character that always finds himself you
know at the right place at the right
time with the most fascinating
individual and a great story to boot
from that so maybe talk a little bit
about how you how you you know really
made that a priority and a fundamental
part of Who You Are
I think that one of the things that you
learn in sports is that if you just get
stuck in your own training routine
and not learn from other people
that you would never become a champion
and uh so open-mindedness was very
important to me and so I think like I
said in my book I learned a lot of my
lessons from Sports and to me that kind
of like and having people like a Freddie
grossel uh that Mentor that talked about
open-mindedness and learning from others
and uh where you start as you get older
you start thinking about all of those
things because you become wiser first it
doesn't mean anything when he told me
that
this is what the Nazis did Arnold they
took my brother's head and they smashed
it in
with a stone
they stoned him to death and I was lucky
to be able to escape and blah blah blah
so you hear that it didn't mean anything
you know uh I said that's really sad but
then it it's those kind of stories
as you grow up yeah and as you get older
they mean something to you and all of a
sudden you find yourself
fighting for
inclusion
and against prejudice
and you ask yourself when does that come
from the desire of he said it comes from
stories like that you know that you
remember from way back when people tell
you those kind of things so to me it was
always kind of like learning new things
and uh being able to uh the boy become a
celebrity to be able to use that
celebrity power
for something positive for something
good and so to me it was I learned the
more I opened up my mind the better it
was there was a guy by the name of Vince
giranda
you maybe have heard of him since you're
a fitness fanatic yourself uh that it he
had a gym over in the valley Vince's gym
and I saw him doing an exercise a
triceps exercise
and I I looked at him I said what are
you doing I just said this is for the
outside tricep that splits the one head
from the other endorse
that's it this looks like a kind of a
Mickey Mouse exercise Jesus Christ and
it doesn't look like some heavy lift of
some sort and he says we'll just try it
so I said to myself well
the way you try it the way I tried it in
those days was I would do an exercise
40 cents of 20 reps
so I was lying there on the bench on my
back digging this dumbbell and going
like this 20 times and take it over to
this side do the same thing over here
same to this arm back and forth back and
forth like this the next day this muscle
here was just jumping all over the place
so I realized he was absolutely correct
I never ever thought of that there's
actually a specific muscle we always
know about sculpting your body that you
you add my chest or more serratus
muscles I'll say m obliques or some
biceps but then you can actually dissect
it to a specific part of the three
muscles that's why it's called triceps
the three muscles there and one
separates the bicep from the tricep and
makes it appear not that measurement
Wise It's bigger but makes it appear
much larger so I was doing that and that
exists from that point on and it just it
was I said to myself I wouldn't have
listened to him I would have never
learned that exercise but I listened to
him I first said them brushed it off I
said Mickey Mouse eggs
let's just try it before we kind of like
come to the conclusion and she wouldn't
have said so you learn from those kind
of experiences he did then apply this
rule with everything and so that's why I
was always
uh rather more hungry for more
information
more hungry for listening rather than
talking
setting aside bias and judgment and
replacing it with curiosity and
basically uh trying it yourself right
like being an experimenter being open
yeah exactly yeah and so imagine I talk
at Great Lengths I was in the book about
how the capital
Sacramento
even though it was a place that I
thought
the people that worked there had no
quality
because they ran they stayed into the
ground by 2003.
and we were bankrupt and the huge
deficits 30 40 billion dollar deficit
and all of that stuff and every
everything they had blackouts and
everyone was unhappy
but when I got there
I realized that there's a lot of things
that I can learn because there's so many
issues policy issues I'm not aware of
and so it actually became kind of the
greatest University for me every day I
was learning imagine you're sitting
there and always said that the nurses
come in
the nurse's Union and they talk about
the patient nurses ratio
I've never even heard of that
I said what are they talking about
so they were explaining that it's right
now six to one
but you know one nurse cannot take care
of six patients especially if you have
to lift the patient because they just
had surgery and you have to lift them
and help them up to get to the bathroom
and there was a one nurse alone cannot
do that
except you have a power lifting Champion
is a nurse or something like that that's
not the case in every hospital so they
were explaining that and it
all of a sudden they said oh my God this
is like I never thought about that that
is really interesting and fascinating
things so if the budget uh we should
actually do something about that the
next meeting an hour later the prison
guards come in and they talk about the
overtime that they're tired because they
don't have enough you know people
working in this prisons
and that the the system is meant for a
hundred thousand prisons but at that
point we had 170 000 prisoners
so we are overcrowded overloaded
I had no idea about that
so I learned and then after the meeting
I got my briefings of what could what
are the options that we can do about it
and then the teachers came and then law
enforcement came and said all day long
every day was a learning experience so
to me the things that I learned in
Sacramento was just staggering and so I
just felt like Not only was I happy that
I was able to serve
40 million people and be a public
servant be the governor but also I
became aware of how complicated issues
are and how complicated they can be and
how much thinking it takes and how much
listening that it takes to bring all the
different ideas together to come up with
a good conclusion to those kind of
issues and problems yeah I mean I think
that was surprising for a lot of people
there was a sensibility that you're
great in front of the camera you know
how to you know get out in front and
shake hands and smile and do all of that
kind of upfront stuff to win the
governorship but governing is a
different job altogether what happens
when Arnold's sitting in the chair
behind the desk and actually has to do
the work and get wonky with the policy
stuff how does that you know how's that
going to work with this action star
who's an adrenaline junkie Etc and the
fact that you actually embrace that and
were enthusiastic about what you were
learning every single day about how
things actually work and then trying to
identify Solutions was unexpected for a
lot of people and I think kind of
reflecting on that
thinking about like what is it that
makes Arnold different special there's
lots of answers to that questions to
that question but I think one
one kind of frame that makes sense to me
is this interesting combination of two
different Arnolds on the one hand
you are and you say this in the book
like very much like Julius and twins you
have this wide-eyed almost childlike
um sense of awe and wonder where the
world is just overflowing with
possibility and people are good and
anything is possible
but you pair that I think the talent is
where you pair that with this doer who
understands having a vision understands
setting goals work ethic discipline reps
like all the Practical aspects of
translating the dream into reality and
most people fall it's on a spectrum but
most people kind of fall you know far on
one side of either of those two things
and somehow you find you found a way to
like marry those and I think that's what
is so potent and and unique well
interestingly enough
even my wife
and she knew me really well
she said after I won
she says now
I'm starting to get concerned
yeah because you would come home and say
I can't believe what I learned yeah but
I mean it's like I said what are you
concerned about being one she says what
she says that that seems to me is more
up your alley you found an enemy you go
after him with vengeance like you're
doing bodybuilding and then acting and
all this kind of stuff I said and you go
after them and it's like a competition
so I get that so you were really good at
that and you could shift gears into
politics and you could paint this
perfect picture of California when you
run it and all that stuff so I said but
now
you have to do policy
politics is now
being put aside and if they do policy so
I don't know how many hours you can
actually sit there and listen to this
most boring stuff
that is really subtle stuff that you
maybe it's not your personality
and so she was questioning it and so as
time went on
she said to me she said I can't believe
that you actually like this stuff
because I don't even like it she said to
me I don't even like it Jesus but there
you sit there for hours and hours and
then you have follow-up questions then
you meet people at night after hours
still to learn more about it she says I
don't understand it I said I somehow you
know I I just love the idea of solving
those problems and trying to figure out
why is it
that in Austria
everyone is insured
and in California the richest state in
the Union
not everyone is insured
what's going on here I mean can we not
create a system
that is similar to the one in Austria
but with the private sector involved and
not government running the whole thing
there must be a way so we started going
on and started tackling this very
complicated issue
out of nowhere no one asked me to do
that just trying to figure out how do we
create Health Care in California for
everyone be the first state kind of like
along with Massachusetts that has
Healthcare reform and where everyone is
insured and so it's it's it's just my
curiosity was just there and I asked
myself questions about education why is
it that our education is slipping why
are there are kids not testing as well
why is their reading ability less than
it was 10 years ago so you you get it
you get interest in it because only when
you understand it
and only when you hear the various
different opinions something from the
way right to the way left you need to
hear orders that's why I never looked at
anyone as the enemy when I was governor
I looked at the Democrats Justice like
Partners as I did with the Republicans
did they agree with sometimes they
disagree with other times and stuff like
that but I always felt kind of we have
to all work together because together we
can figure out the sweet spot you know
he says this he says this let's figure
out the sweet spot where we can you know
have something of both of those sides
come together here and so that's the the
way I try to solve the problems and uh I
got fascinated by all these details your
governorship was really defined by your
ability to reach across the aisle and
consensus build with both parties this
this you know sort of
allergy to being a a party hack and
instead you know hiring a chief of staff
who was a Democrat and appointing A
diversity of judges and and doing all
the things that you did
leads me to wonder I mean it's really a
it's really a question around
leadership and problem solving because
right now in 2023
feels pretty divided people are more
interested in in bickering with each
other than solving problems Reaching
Across the aisle is seen as a weakness
and as a result problems don't get
solved so
when you look
out upon the world California the nation
what are you seeing right now in terms
of the leadership that we have the
leadership that we deserve
that perhaps we're lacking first of all
let me tell you
that
I did not experience
any of that whenever I went to
Washington I mean they all talk about it
but
every president after Clinton Clinton
put 1.3 billion dollars into the 21st
century money which is for after school
programs
and after that every president wanted to
take it out of the budget so
since I was like
the
kind of the big deal in the after-school
program movement
they asked me the the national after
school program Association asked me to
go and help them Lobby in Washington so
we went back there to Lobby the Bush
Administration and everyone's talking
about that is you're gonna bring them
together they fight over that you know
the Republicans want to take it out and
the Democrats want to keep it in and
blah blah blah notice if
and I asked them I said I found friends
and Californians and they said can you
help me bring three Senators together
from the Democrats and three from the
Republicans
and to talk about after school programs
I want to just talk to them have a
meeting
and they did
and the same was in the house
they got from you know Congress people
men and women they got together a whole
bunch of them Democrats and Republicans
intermed with them
I presented my case told them how
important it is to keep this after
school programs why it was wise
showed them the statistics and the
studies that when they said for every
dollar we spent on an after school
program we saved three to six dollars
down the line and blah blah blah
they all shook hands
that when the bill comes up
and when the debate comes up that they
will fight
and they would tell their colleagues
to also fight to keep it in the budget
I walked away and I said the first place
that is supposed to be so split and that
they're fighting all the time I didn't
see that fight
not understand it not in the house
we then went back in the Obama
Administration he wanted to take out the
money
we went back again because he gained a
team together totally different people
now again Democrats and Republicans work
together and we kept it in
so every single time a president every
time I went back there I did not see
that the Democrats and the Republicans
didn't want to work together
I begged them
to work together for the sake of the
kids I said I'm a Republican
I said but this is nothing to do with
Republican democrators Democratic kids
and Republican kids
I said yes the Republicans say that this
is like the government is babysitting
and all this stuff I understand that I
totally agree with you I said but when
it comes to being out on the streets
and uh
being in reality
it doesn't work that way because 80
percent of the kids come from homes for
both parents are working so therefore
there couldn't be anyone at home I just
said let's and they both right eyes did
they the first time they really heard
about someone talking passionately about
it and they voted for it and it kept it
in the budget and even still the day
it's in a budget um so all is well in
Washington so no I'm just saying it
needs an approach where you don't
villainize I didn't go in there to
villainize the Democrats as a Republican
I says we Republicans here the setting
we have to answer to that but you guys
are always voting now on this so no
it was not that approach so it's it's
the approach that you have to take and
I'm talking about and you ask about
leadership it needs the kind of
leadership that has the energy to not
worry so much about the specific policy
but to First bring the team together
this is what someone has to do in
Washington
to those members
rally them together
yes there will be different ways of
thinking and all this stuff but you got
to Rally it and again says here's why
and make the case of where America needs
to go and what we need to accomplish
from immigration reform to Health Care
reform to uh getting rid of the debt
getting rid of the of the debt deficit
that we have
and to solve and to build infrastructure
in order to talk about this they added
and to have a strong military they can
stand up to the Chinese and to the
Russians and do the whole world and that
that the only can do with Democrats and
Republicans together we cannot do it
alone Republicans cannot do it alone
then you have a total up where this
is some executive order like they've
done and then Biden runs off with his
executive orders which the next
president wipes out again it's bogus the
only thing that sticks is if Democrats
and Republicans come together and they
meet in the middle
and that the answer to the people rather
than the special interests
and so you need someone that rallies
them up and that's what I'm talking
about that's what it needs because I was
back there
with my friend Kevin McCarthy
he asked me to talk to his
environmentalists
now of course you will laugh because
they're Republicans and say where are
the environmentalists well there are
they maybe don't buy into this climate
change
so we don't talk about climate change to
these guys
you talk to them about pollution because
no one can deny pollution
every Republican they've talked to said
you love pollution and said no are you
kidding me I said you want to fight
pollution of course
we want to get rid of pollution I said
but then we have to get rid of oil and
all of this stuff and just build my
nuclear plants and more renewable
energies yeah I'm important that with
that
so it's it's the way you approach it you
have to find a way in you have to
communicate effectively you have to
understand the needs and desires of the
people that you're trying to build
consensus with and the after school
program context
it meant approaching Republicans with an
economic argument that this is going to
save money and the Democrats with the
idea that it's important you know from a
democratic sensibility to have
government involved in supporting these
youths in the environmental context what
you're saying is you can't go with some
muddled Trope that is not going to
connect with those people you have to
find something that they're that they
care about address that and craft your
narrative and your argument around that
strategically so that you can build that
consensus and that team comes comes
together to actually solve a problem
that's what you're saying and the
there's people that's supposed to be the
smart people
they don't get it
they keep asking back to sell sell
they're telling this story that's that's
what it is it's communicating because
we're in California
we accomplished all of those
environmental laws because we
communicated with the people the right
way
when we said to the people when it's a
hot date don't put the thermostat down
at 68 put it on 74. and that they were
helpful
during my Administration there was no
blackout the blackouts were in the
previous administration of the blackouts
so we communicated with the people they
were on our side and we said to them I
said and we have to build renewable we
have now 19 renewable by the time I'm
finished I'm gonna have 50 renewable
was no one saying no or anything like
this because they they realized that
there would be anywhere we need to go
and when the oil companies and the coal
companies tried to derail us we fought
them with the help of the American Lung
Association to show that the people of
California what happens if you keep
using oil
that the kids in the Central Valley and
all over California are getting asthma
at the age of three
and they're very very sick and they're
dying is that what we wanted to do with
our kids and they said oh my God I
didn't know that
instead of talking about climate change
20 years from now or something like that
it's you and I believe in it but the
majority of people don't understand what
it means so therefore let's talk about
pollution like Ronald Reagan Ronald
Reagan established the air resources
board in California that actually makes
every law that we pass become a reality
so if I say there is a law that is 50
reduction of of of fossil fuels they
make it happen so we said 25 in 10 years
they made it happen so this is what
Ronald Reagan established under the
auspices of we got to fight pollution he
didn't talk about climate change
you know so this is why I say it it is
just that we have to sell we have to
communicate we have to include people we
have to bring them in we have to explain
it to them and often and not everyone
talking in a different direction and and
you know
Biden's does its speeches the day I want
to talk about climate
I said but what wouldn't it be much
better the day I want to talk with you
about how we can get rid of pollution
hit the nail in the head he knows that
this is what I'm talking about I think
that's what when we talk about
leadership that's what we need in
Washington now is just to bring people
together communicate the right way not
step in someone's toe and and make them
scream no just let's let's figure out
things that we can do together I mean I
went to Sacramento the first thing we
did was we try to figure out what we can
do together and then we worried about
the more difficult stuff that that we
are in different directions and stuff
like that
I want to talk a little bit about your
passion uh for for the environment
um I imagine that Jim Cameron
has been uh part of that Journey for you
and one of the things that's interesting
it is interesting about an aspect of
this this journey that you're on with
this is that you uh have come out and
advocated for people to eat less meat uh
to have a more plant-based oriented
lifestyle you were involved with the
game changers movie
um so I'm curious around and I'm sure
the the bodybuilding Community had an
interesting reaction to that I've been
plant-based for 16 years at this point
and I'm friends with a lot of the people
in that movie and very much a part of
that movement so I'm curious around how
you got involved in
in that film and what your diet looks
like now
well I got involved because of Jim
Cameron yeah and the other people that
were involved and they asked me if I
wanted to talk about it because they
knew that I have mentioned it
through Jim Cameron in the past that
I've cut back on my meat intake because
of uh
in the medical profession it's very
clear that you get away with this
for so long and then eventually it
starts backfiring and so they thought
that I'm at an age now where I should
just cut back because my cholesterol
level should come down a little bit and
blood pressure and all that and that's
exactly what I did you know so I started
cutting out so my diet is pretty much I
would if I put the percentage on it then
I'm pretty good at that I would say
around 70 percent I cut down my middle
intake
and the other 30 percent is on it
because of my
um every so often I once a month maybe I
make a steak at home when we watch the
UFC fights it somehow fits together
with all the mid up to the screen yeah
even though there is a lot of UFC
fighters out there that also vegetable
based uh but in any case so it's it's
someone fits together and I like to do
it it's just the process also to
actually barbecue so this is why I said
30 knot and 70 cut down yeah yeah yeah
um but Jim had a big impact on you Jimmy
in many ways but Jim is a big impact on
me because he not only
confirmed
what I told him about health-wise how
much better it is health-wise
but he confirmed that
but he also said that and don't forget
Arnold
that 25 or 28 percent
of all the pollution comes from Raising
livestock
and it's as if we just would cut that
out we would have much less pollution so
from an environmental point of view it's
better and from a you know personal
point of view health-wise so it's
healthier for your body and it's
healthier for you for our Earth
answer there was his message and so Jim
has
never that I'm aware of ever said
anything to me
about anything that wasn't true
when I was governor
and I went and as we usually go in our
motorcycle rides
and we were sitting over there at the
rock store
and he said he says
um someone to bring out the reverse
metering
he says pay attention to that
I found out when I went to Sacramento
yeshu enough that if someone
puts solar on their building let's say
of a huge warehouse and you produce so
much electricity
because of all this solar that you
covered the whole top of the warehouse
that you have spear electricity that you
want to send it back to the grid so
other people can use it and you get paid
for it or get credit for it from the
power companies
that the power companies just doesn't
want that they don't like that no they
want to produce their own which means
more fossil fuels and more damage to our
Earth so I then started fighting and
started really working in that direction
so that they do accept reverse metering
so it's things like that that no one
would even know
what Jim Cameron is talking about
and uh and I've immediately picked up on
it but it just shows to you also how
smart is I mean especially with the
technological things and technology and
with little details and he reads a lot
and all itself just so experienced so
you know he was always a great guy to
talk to and I always learned from him a
lot I mean the other day he came to me
oh what the other day the other month he
came to me and he said
and I had this stomach problem
and uh
the doctor says just don't eat
for a few days
and I say okay
so is there the need for a few days so
yeah the normal wisdom would tell us we
run out of energy
he says would you believe that they had
more energy on the set he says and as
soon as they ate my first meal he says
my energy dropped he says of course
eventually we have to eat we can't live
without food he says but the bottom line
is
that
eating lunch when you're on a set does
not make you
become more energetic it robs you of
energy
because the blood or rushes you get
tired and he says that's why we have
French hours on a set which means you
can eat throughout the day but there was
no more lunch break because this is a
waste of two hours of people's
performance and he's right
is absolutely right when I don't eat in
the morning I go to the gym I work out
and I don't have breakfast and
everything like this comes 12 o'clock at
one o'clock when I do something I'm us
I'm so energetic
but as soon as you eat
at nine o'clock after my workout and
after my bike ride I go home and I sit
down and I start reading something like
this
I kind of like doze off right this is
It's amazing so he again he was right so
I I just think that so many things that
he has taught me and told me Jim was
always right well to say he's a
detail-oriented person is to understate
it
you know
um he's a somebody who who meets you in
that place where uh nothing is going to
get in the way of of basically achieving
your goal at the level that you aspire
to achieve it right right
um but most people are not wired that
way no you know you're walking the Earth
with a certain
like sort of default operating system
that other people lack which maybe makes
it easier for you to accomplish your
goals but also perhaps might be
frustrating because it's hard not to
like want people to kind of be operating
on your level and now you have this book
where you're sharing like here's how I
did it here's what you can learn from my
experience here are the principles that
um kind of created the the playing field
for me to do all of these things
what is the process from your
perspective of trying to get people to
to grab onto these things and take
responsibility because you can't
willingness you can't engender
willingness in another person right they
either they either like want to achieve
a goal or they don't and you can give
them all the tools and say do this but
what you can't do is actually instigate
them into action or maybe you can then
how do you think about that no no you
can
I know what you're saying but it is
interesting how sometimes
people listen to you and an interview or
they talk to you in person
and there's something you say
maybe not even intentional
where did they say that's what did it
that's what triggered
something in me
that I want to go now and set the goal
for myself and do x y and z
so it it can be the hardest thing I
myself get motivated a lot of times when
they watch something big coincidence or
watch a documentary or I hear something
um it triggers something and then it
motivates you to go in a certain
direction so I think to disregard that
it would be a mistake I think that we
have to do everything that we can and
since I by accident
fell into this
thing here
becoming a motivational speaker because
yeah ten years ago it was an accident
totally accident yeah 10 years ago when
I was doing uh or or more than that uh
15 years ago
when I was doing a commencement speech
at USC and they talked about dma just to
to motivate the kids when they graduate
uh here's my sixth
in the points by six rules to success
from that point on people kept asking me
to finally do a book why don't you do a
book why don't you do a book and I just
said I'm not this is not the business
I'm in but then all of a sudden
people that I got in the speaker speaker
circuit
yeah you know the president's usually on
um or ex-presidents I should say
and um and all of a sudden I'm traveling
around and I'm doing speeches with
Clinton somewhere in Africa and then
yeah and uh with various different
leaders and everyone is asking me to do
a motivational speech not to talk about
policy not about the environment not
about the governorship or anything or
about bodybuilding no a motivational
speech
they want to have the six rules so the
seven rules so the ten rules whatever it
takes they want to know that they always
say this look we're having five thousand
people from Real Estate there pumped
them up we got together and get more
sales and power and so that's obviously
and I fell into this groove of of kind
of where people say you know this is so
motivational what you're saying this is
so great this is exactly what we needed
through a book and then the family I did
the book hmm what is your
relationship with it like in terms of of
how it makes you feel like compared to
being the biggest movie star in the
world compared to being Governor
compared to uh you know winning all
those titles as a bodybuilder
um you spoke earlier about
how you can become addicted to that
um feeling that you get when you're
helping somebody else right and this is
this is a very palpable powerful way of
you reaching out to people directly and
having that impact on them does it feel
different than what it felt like when
you were Governor or when you were you
know doing the big movies
is it the same
like the gratification that you get from
um from it all I think it all feels good
yeah you know but I mean it's also a big
change
I'm a different person sitting here the
day than I was when I was 20 years old
and won my first Mr Universe contest can
imagine so to me that was the most
important thing in my life
this was like unbelievable
but
then came with a day
Where I Stood on that stage and then one
Mr Olympia even a bigger title than Mr
Universe I didn't mean anything I said
that these guys that I just beat they
would be much happy with the title than
I am
so I'm out of here
and that was it I quit
and I went into acting
so
then all of a sudden that becomes the
most important thing to go in the ring a
big box office to have a successful
movie to go from action to comedian from
Comedy to action and it isn't that into
two all those kind of things that
becomes the most important thing
but then in 2003 when I finished my
promotion to for pump for for Terminator
three
and they had the recall election here
I said to myself
this is what I should do I should run
for governor
what the hell is this is this isn't the
same thing am I going to go now for the
Terminator you know 4 and 16 and 20 and
Conan 14 or something yeah what life is
about and there must be more than that
so all of a suddenly is that looking for
the in a
to what they're called the PPD right the
big and bigger better deal and decides I
started looking for something more spicy
that's more risky and that it is bigger
for me and to me as him as a policy
that's that's something that is a new
challenge that could be really great and
I stepped into that Arena so it's we
changed and we changed and so what was
one time to me the most important thing
and the most exciting thing
you know the day's not and so this is
now exciting to be able to motivate
people to be better
and um
to go and to fight for the environment
and to uh you know promote uh democracy
and uh to terminate
gerrymandering and the oldest kind of
issues in the do to run the
Schwarzenegger Institute and to make
students you know kind of learn
firsthand of what it's about to become a
leader and all that stuff at the
University so those are the kind of
things the day that means something to
me so it it's an evolution as I get
older and as I get wiser and as I get
better and smarter and all of that stuff
things change I want to be conscious of
your time I gotta let you go but perhaps
thank God yeah yeah I'm gonna get you
out of here are you bored no no I want
to give you a little like last
last opportunity for a little schmei you
know like what is it that you want
people to get out of this book what do
you think is holding people back the
most how are you messaging these people
lighting a fire under their ass trying
to get them pumped up and on a new
better trajectory you know this is
simply to make people better and to make
them recognize that they don't have to
get stuck where they are but they can
change
because every every day is an
opportunity of change and so I want them
to look at this book and just say maybe
there's something in that they will
motivate me to change and to get better
to improve myself and I have to get
stuck in this I can shoot for big course
I want people to be aware of it that you
don't have to shoot for little goals but
you can shoot for big cores that it is
just as difficult to shoot for a little
goal than to shoot for a big goal and I
want them to know that they shouldn't be
afraid of failure that this comes
naturally in life there will be failure
and there will be successes the
important thing is that we learn from
that but not to be Frozen and to be the
fear that I want them to know that they
have to create a vision of where they
want to go without a vision there is
just nowhere to go you use it's it's
just the way it is in life you were just
wander around without a mission without
the joy of chasing something how much
fun it is to chase something so I want
them to learn those basic lessons that
make you just more successful and better
hmm
you're speaking my language thank you
for that uh that was beautifully put
you're an international Treasurer it uh
meant a lot to me for you to spend time
today so I thank you for that thank you
appreciate it keep up all your athletic
activities
yeah it's like amazing
the guy that can at any given time walk
from my office over to the beach and
swim to Hawaii I wish how many people
can do that I wish I mean that's that's
unbelievable anyway
um you did a great job yeah thank you
keep up the good work okay appreciate it
be useful available everywhere it's
going to be impossible to avoid you I
think probably in coming weeks uh
so it's going to be uh the book is going
to be everywhere it's going to be it
thank you I loved it and I appreciate
you thank you cheers it was fun writing
thanks thank you
[Music]
that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at richroll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change and
the plant power away as well as the
plant power meal planner at
meals.richeral.com if you'd like to
support the podcast the easiest and most
impactful thing you can do is to
subscribe to the show on Apple podcasts
on Spotify and on YouTube and leave a
review and or comment
supporting the sponsors who support the
show is also important and appreciated
and sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at ritual.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason camiolo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davey Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel Solis thank
you Georgia Whaley for copywriting and
website management and of course our
theme music was created by Tyler Pyatt
Trapper piatt and Harry Mathis
appreciate the love love the support
see you back here soon peace plants
[Music]
thank you